What we want is a function called "test"
which takes a string s--this would be the HTML input--
and if this HTML input s would cause Mozilla to crash, tests should return fail,
otherwise, it should return pass.
We're simply going to search whether s contains a select tag.
For this we set up a simple regular expression,
which says if there is a some substring in s
which consists of an opening tag, select, and then an arbitrary number of characters
which are not a closing tag--that is not a greater sign--
this is expressed by this caret over here, meaning not the greater sign--
not the greater sign and then star meaning 0 or more instances of that
and finally a closing tag.
So we can have a less than sign, select, then anything except for a greater than sign,
and finally a greater than sign.
This is what makes an HTML tag.
If this occurs within our string, we return fail.
Otherwise, we return pass.
This regular expression requires a function from the RE module,
but we first need to import this.
So, let's see what happens if we feed in a just a regular HTML tag
into the testing function.
What we get is pass, because there is no select tag in here.
Let's expand this a bit, and now let's actually add a select tag in here
as in this example.
Now we see that our output changes to fail,
because in here we actually do have a select tag.
So this is what our testing function does.
It simply simulates the behavior of Mozilla.
Normally, we would pass this input to Mozilla and then see whether it crashes or not,
but in order to keep things simple, we're simply having this simple testing function,
which checks directly for what is supposed to be in the input.